you're a young kid i want to [ __ ]
hurt you sometimes i really do when i
look at the videos you know what i mean
i want to go i i i don't want to get but
i have to [ __ ] with that
thank you man i'm [ __ ] with it so
when's the netflix when is it
it's out it's out yeah it's out now it's
uh you guys can go check it out man
it's a schultz saves america that's what
it is yeah yeah and then what else do
you have going on
nothing yeah are you doing a lot of
stand up or no
no i haven't done any actually either
either yeah
and and weirdly enough i haven't desired
it yeah i think
like my creative juices were fueled by
this project that just took so much
[ __ ] time
yeah it was okay and then weirdly enough
like doing pods
like and hanging around not my own pod
like doing other people's pods
especially if there's like people in the
room
i start to miss stand up a little bit
because it almost feels like you're like
you know you i'm hearing you tell a
funny story like even when you were
telling me that story earlier in this
podcast i'm like yeah that'd be a good
bit man there's like a lot of hate
because it sounds the story sounds like
you're bragging about banging this hot
chick but it really
it just i'm like oh [ __ ] man i miss
being on stage yeah yeah
you know but at the same time i'm like
i'm not gonna perform in like 20 degree
weather on a roof
yeah you know for me it's not i don't
yeah like that's not how i want to do it
people are like calling me dude there's
a great [ __ ] beach show
and i go yeah show me a photo right yeah
and they're outside
people are [ __ ] 500 feet away from
the stage
yeah six feet apart right i need to hear
a laughter i want you close yes
comfortable
yes yes yeah you know i'm the type of
comic that like
energy bro not energy i uh that but also
i like to like
i like to grab people behind the head i
don't know what i meant by like you feed
off their energy yeah like
you gotta connect to them yeah yeah yeah
like you pl have you played the denver
comedy works yeah yeah yeah you know how
close they are yeah yeah right i just
like going what's up bro
yeah yeah i'm here you know i mean and
like you know i mean
farting on somebody yeah or like you
know me doing what i do you know what i
mean but it's like i can't do these vast
you know like i'm doing it like a mad
max [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah what i mean it
feels spoken word
yeah yeah it feels like a little spoken
word like you can go up there and you
can like
do your misdirection bits and stuff yeah
or like a joke like a story that has a
big like twist at the end or something
it will work
but the connectivity is definitely
different and i i thrive off that like i
want when i'm with you i want to feel
your energy
yeah when i'm silent and you guys are
like waiting for the line i want to feel
that you also do a lot of improv too i
see you know
i've seen bits you know what i mean so
how do you really riff in all that stuff
when they're like 14 feet away
yeah yeah yeah what are you wearing no
really what yeah
yeah yeah yeah it is it will come back
that's what i'm not tripping about like
it's gonna come back and then we'll be
back out there but like yeah
and shout out to everybody who's doing
the shows like yeah yeah yeah
in new york like the seller just closed
then they started to do like these
dinner shows
but the whole time new york comedy club
was like shout out to emilio they were
[ __ ]
hustling dude like they started putting
shows on [ __ ] roofs man and in the
summer it was fire
like it was literally like peep you
could see across the river
and like people are on this like lit
roof and they were doing like they were
finding outdoor areas they just [ __ ]
hustled man
yeah it was so impressive to see yeah
and um obviously now it's cold
you know and everything's shut down in
new york again it's annoying but
i don't know i i just i hope we can get
back to it man
i know i'm sorry i'm so sorry it's so
rude what happened you got a call oh you
don't know how to turn your own
i silent okay an hour after
well you should've said it the first
time it happened i did it kept looking
at you but my eyes
are not visible that's your fault that's
your badge i have laser eyes
i i know i'm so sorry i just turned it
off another thing from the duplex oh god
oh god
i hate him so much so we're doing it
tuesday
oh my gosh